[Musique]
je
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky échos le
magazine qui vous racontent la vie des
acteurs économiques du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes chez un des leader mondial
du secteur de la santé le groupe
allemand merck
ils fabriquent des médicaments développe
des solutions et des outils destinés à
la médecine mais aussi pour les
laboratoires de recherche
parmi ces 11 implantations en france le
centre de recherches et de
développements marketing basé à
guyancourt spécialisée dans les systèmes
de purification d'eau
c'est ce que vous découvrirez dans ce
21e numéro du sky échos installé depuis
plusieurs années à guyancourt le groupe
merck développent des innovations autour
des purificateurs d'eau un leader
mondial dans ce domaine
plus d'une centaine de dirigeants de
grands groupes mondiaux ont été invités
par le président de la république au
château de versailles
parmi eux beleng alejo la pdg du groupe
merck
elle s'est confiée à nous enfin
découverte du food truck cikiqui un
projet entrepreneurial aux saveurs des
cinq continents
lancé par deux soeurs iny montée
[Musique]
retour sur l'événement de choses france
au château de versailles et le président
de la république emmanuel macron a reçu
plus d'une centaine de dirigeants de
grands groupes venant du monde entier
objectif favoriser l'attractivité
économique de la france parmi eux la 6e
du groupe merck beleng allirot elle nous
a parlé de l'activité sur le site de
guyancourt dans lequel nous nous
trouvons et de son importance
stratégique pour le groupe mr que dans
le monde notamment sur le travail de
l'innovation sur la purification de
l'eau et vous le voyez autour de moi
avec l'ensemble de ses brevets déposés
sur ces produits
on écoute tout de suite dans cette
interview express nous avons un site ici
près de versailles parmi l ensemble des
sites que nous avons en france
ce site est dédié à la purification de
l'eau des systèmes conçus par les 250
collaborateurs que nous avons sur ce
site
ces outils sont utilisés pour des
objectifs académiques de la recherche et
dans l'industrie pharmaceutique d'austin
powers ces sites est important pour
notre activité en france mais aussi pour
une autre activité à l'international
dans notre activité sciences de la vie
l'un des services que nous rendons c'est
la purification de l'eau et ceux ci
contribuent à servir nos clients sur ce
segment d'activité
[Musique]
oui à nous allons continuer à développer
ce business sur le long terme et nous
sommes ravis des performances de ces
sites
[Musique]
on vient d'entendre près de 250
collaborateurs travaillent ici sur le
site de merck à guyancourt un centre de
recherches et de développements
marketing pour concevoir des systèmes de
purification d'eau a une activité un
présentes sur le territoire depuis plus
de 30 ans d'abord millipore puis merck
depuis 2010 et pour en parler nous
sommes avec renault bars dont le
dirigeant de ce site bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
quel métier on retrouve ici on retrouve
beaucoup de types de métiers
principalement de niveau bac +5 et
doctorants et en général on a des bien
sûr des scientifiques pour tout ce qui
est purification de l'eau des chimistes
des biochimistes mais aussi nous avons
et ça c'est un petit peu moins connu
beaucoup avec la transformation digitale
de besoin en électronicien informaticien
et bien sûr comme c'est un sens
marketing de fonctions marketing donc
toutes ces activités sont dédiés à la
purification de l'eau des systèmes qui
permettent de purifier l'eau c'est ça
oui en fait on est très fiers d'être les
leaders du marché au niveau mondial et
toute la recherche et développement et
le marketing sont faits à partir du sud
de guyancourt alors quelle est la
stratégie autour de cette innovation
la stratégie allait elle est multiple la
première c'est de garder ce leadership
bien sûr et tout ça en misant sur
l'innovation l'innovation mais aussi la
qualité et comme je vous le disais cette
transformation digitale dont beaucoup
parlent et qui est une réelle réalité
pour nous puisque nous avons par exemple
la possibilité de
consulter les données de nos systèmes à
distance ce qui pendant le coc vide a
été critique pour de nombreux hôpitaux
de pouvoir compter sur leurs systèmes de
purification d'eau et de savoir qu'on
n'avait pas besoin de venir sur site
pour consulter leurs leurs performances
comment vous l'expliquez ce leadership
on a une très très bonne recherche et
développement avec des gens très
compétents
nous faisons partie du plateau pas loin
de saclay avec beaucoup de très bonnes
écoles
pareil pour le marketing ne rejouer en
josas on à hec qui est pas loin et c'est
donc une qualité de la ressource qui est
très très bonne
autour de lui en cours merci renaud
bardon merci beaucoup à vous je rappelle
que vous êtes le dirigeant du site de
merck à guyancourt et on va tout de
suite rejoindre perrine projet votre
directrice marketing pour voir comment
fonctionnent ces systèmes de
purification d'eau
[Musique]
nous avons rejoint terrine frogé la
directrice marketing du groupe merck sur
le site de guyancourt bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue
[Musique]
merci nous accueillir dans un
laboratoire où on voit différents
systèmes de purification d'eau alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer à
quoi servent ces systèmes tout à fait
alors ce qu'il faut savoir déjà c'est
que l'eau de ville bien qu'elle soit
propre à notre consommation contient
beaucoup de composer ionique ou
organiques qui ne sont pas compatibles
avec les expérimentations scientifiques
notre rôle c'est de concevoir des
systèmes qui vont purifier cet autre
ville pour la rendre propre à
l'utilisation par les scientifiques
que ce soit dans la recherche contre la
cancérologie par exemple en cancérologie
ou pour ce soit des analyses chimiques
dans l'environnement l'alimentaire est
en fait ces systèmes servent à la
recherche scientifique c'est l'eau
utilisée dans les recherches
scientifiques ans et ça c'est un composé
indispensable un réactif indispensable
pour la recherche scientifique
c'est également absolument essentiel
pour les laboratoires de biologie
clinique qui ont été au coeur de la
lutte contre le coc vide nos systèmes
permettent le bon fonctionnement de ces
laboratoires et donc nous avons nous
avons été très impliquée dans la
continuité du service et le support à
ces laboratoires dans les derniers mois
c'est le système qui sont utilisés dans
la production de vaccins par exemple
dans la recherche dans le cadre de
production de vaccins ils sont tout à
fait utiliser dans le cadre de la
recherche de production de vaccins dans
le cadre des contrôles qualité à des
vaccins donc là dans le cap de la crise
votre activité marketing a été essentiel
de spawn notre activité non seulement
marketing mais aussi innovation support
à nos clients dans des conditions
d'acompte connaît voilà donc oui nous
avons été très présent et très sollicité
alors concrètement comment ça fonctionne
en fait ce système alors c'est sont des
systèmes qui embarque différentes
technologies de purification donc de la
filtration de l'osmose inverse de la
photo oxydation iv mais aussi beaucoup
de technologie de contrôle pour vraiment
être capable de mesurer le degré
purification et de restituer aux clients
toutes les informations dont il a besoin
au moment où il va l'utiliser
alors vous allez utiliser plusieurs
termes techniques concrètement comment
on purifient l'eau en fait qu'est-ce qui
agit au niveau microscopique finalement
alors l'ol va passer dans des colonnes
de charbon actif par exemple qui vont
capter les contaminants
elle va être soumis donc à la photo
oxydation iv qui va tuer les bactéries
donc en fait chaque étape de
purification va permettre d'atteindre un
degré de purification plus élevée de
l'eau pour au final ne garder que l'eau
ultra purs qui va permettre la conduite
des expérimentations renault garde on
nous disait tout à l'heure que
finalement vous utilisez beaucoup
liothier aujourd'hui s'est connecté en
fait ce sont des appareils connectés
et puis on peut les piloter à distance
en fait exactement donc ce sont des
encore une fois la purification est très
importante mais là tout le contrôle de
cette purification la mesure permanente
des paramètres de qualité des eaux est
essentiel et aujourd'hui nos
technologies permettent de donner ces
paramètres à nos clients bien qu'il ne
soit pas devant leur système donc ils
peuvent consulter la performance de
leurs systèmes à 10 ans
nous sommes aussi en mesure de réparer
leur système à distance c'est à dire que
vous êtes au début de la filière jusqu'à
la fin de la filière de la purification
de l'eau sur dans le cadre de la santé
tout à fait dans le cadre des sciences
de la vie avec des applications en santé
notamment
merci perrine projets pour ces détails
avec grand plaisir que vous êtes la
directrice marketing du groupe merck sur
le site de guyancourt
[Musique]
elles ont lancé leurs activités le 1er
juillet 2021 fanja et lalatiana
rakotomamonjy ont ouvert leur hug
baptisée ticket psy qui elle propose des
plats multiculturelle venant des quatre
coins du monde c'est la séquence ma vie
d'entrepreneur avec fanja elana tiana
rakotomamonjy
[Musique]
il
je suis fanja rakotomamonjy cofondatrice
de sic et était un fou trucks spécialisé
dans la cuisine du monde que j'ai créé
avec ma soeur lalatiana rakotomamonjy je
suis la lazio nara quand on a mangé j'ai
cofondé le foot rock avec ma soeur et je
suis responsable de la communication du
marketing et aussi une partie
commerciale
[Musique]
et principalement proposé aux villageois
aux fêtes de voyager à travers à travers
notre cuisine du monde
mon activité a consisté d'abord au début
au montage du projet donc tout ce qui
est prévisionnel est aussi tout ce qui
est plein d'action communication
[Musique]
comme plat on peut trouver aussi bien la
roue des saucisses et crevettes que le
poulet m'a fait que tilikum carnet et
puis au niveau des desserts par lui nous
restons sur des mois le banc de l'as
moelleux
chocolat passion à moi le patates douces
banni j'ai surtout sont des masseurs sur
ce qu'elle voulait faire son besoin son
rêve avoir quelque chose de concret et
voilà cette chose concrète c'est ce fou
de truck et ça ça rassemble un peu ce
que je fais de la cuisine et si on est
un peu allez voir à aller à la rencontre
des gens
[Musique]
on a recherché les conseils localement
au début par le ski tube puis par le par
le bijou nous avons pour l'étude de
marché au niveau consommateurs et fait
réaliser un questionnaire à son âge en
ligne ça nous a permis de cadrer l'offre
n'ont pas et puis pour la partie de
concurrence on l'a fait par nous mêmes
par des recherches sur internet
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez la revoir en
rites et sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]